[Musique]
donc c'est en a un pour mille cinq cents
donc index américain des mille 500
premières entreprises
savez vous qu'il y a plus de dirigeants
ça plante jaune que de femmes
alors il ya trente ans il ya 40 ans on
aurait pu dire mais c'est normal
le temps que les femmes arrivent sur le
marché du travail qu elle se forme
qu'elles accèdent aux études supérieures
mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y a plus de matière grise
féminine qui sort de l'enseignement
supérieur que de matière grise masculine
très exactement en europe
56 % des diplômés de l'enseignement
supérieur sont des femmes alors ma
question c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe à
partir du moment où les femmes arrivent
en bloc sur le marché du travail avec
leur cerveau gonflé à bloc aussi et dix
quinze vingt années plus tard on les
retrouve pas à la tête des entreprises
qu'est ce qui se passe sur cette route
là c'est comme si elles ont marqué et
puis les premières années ça se passe
bien et un moment donné il y à des
perturbations telles qu'on les perde du
radar un moment donné il y avait
perturbations telles qu'elles rentrent
carrément dans un trou à rats
des perturbations tellement forte je
fais même pas 10% 20% de femmes qui
passent à la trappe
mais 90 % de femmes alors on le sait on
connaît les causes grâce sellings 1970
fin 1970 servi quand même 40 ans et les
hommes aujourd'hui vivent les dirigeants
d'entreprises disent mais on aimerait
bien nos et des dirigeants d'entreprise
mais où sont elles les responsables de
médias disent on adorerait avoir des
expertes à la télé à la radio dans la
presse mais où les trouver et les
responsables d'événements cediv on
aimerait bien avoir plus de speaker
femme a aujourd'hui une
mais comment les trouver et donc ce
plafond de verre qui était identifiée en
1970 le déconstruire le faire atomiser
on n'a pas régalé à la petite cuillère
non plus c'est vraiment devenu une
ambition pour moi et même plus que ça
une obsession déconstruire la barrière
du genre pour que chaque femme puisse
accéder au job qu'elle soit et que vous
comme moi on puisse aussi participer à
la société de demain
parce que dans la bataille il ya quand
même 56% des cerveaux qui s'enraye
or pour construire le monde de demain
on a besoin de tous ces cerveaux là
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis pas
mal d'années je me suis donné pour
mission de de ne pas accepter cette
phase fatalité du plafond de verre mais
vraiment de trouver les outils pour le
pulvériser nous sommes en 2000 j'habite
aux états unis à la police dans le
mariage
et là il ya un livre qui paraît à
l'époque et qui bout lance ma vie les
créatifs culturels
comment 50 millions de personnes sont en
train de changer le monde c'est un livre
issu d'une étude américaine menée par un
sociologue et une psychologue et qui
affirme qu' à l'époque 25 % de la
société américaine c'est à dire 50
millions de personnes sont drivés par
quatre valeurs la valeur écologique la
valeur sociétale
la valeur des développements personnels
développement de soi et la valeur
féminine dans le sens où donner plus de
présence est d'importance aux femmes
dans la société
alors les trois premières valeurs moi
j'en ferai mon sujet d'intérêt personnel
aura lieu et la dernière j'en ferai le
fil rouge de ma carrière
ego de mon chemin j'ai trouvé trois
pierres pour exploser ce plafond de
verre et promouvoir la mixité
ce sont trois pierres qui mises ensemble
ont une puissance bien monique donc nous
sommes aux états je suis aux états unis
et je rentre en france après plusieurs
années passées aux états unis et je
cherche du travail
comme ce soit avec les petites annonces
ça marche pas j'active pas le réseau et
je tombe à l'époque sur des réseaux
féminins des réseaux professionnels
féminins et en fait je découvre qu à
chaque fois qu et des femmes dans
l'histoire et même encore aujourd'hui à
chaque fois qu'elles sont confrontées à
une barrière dans leur carrière
elle crée un réseau à chaque fois
qu'elles sont exclus aussi
deux réseaux exclut officiellement dans
les statuts de réseau du coup masculin
comme le jockey club comme l'autonomie
de france comme le rotary jusqu'en 87
interdit aux femmes dans les statuts à
chaque fois qu'elles sont exclues elles
créent un réseau professionnel féminin
pour s'entraider aide solidaire partager
et pouvoir progresser dans leur carrière
et du loup à l'époque jean recense 200
et jean faure un livre en 2007
dix ans plus tard je rassemblerai 200
présidente de réseau pour signer une
charte pour pulvériser le plafond de
verre et en écho personnel je me rends
compte qu'à chaque fois que je les fais
un mot dans ma carrière c'est parce que
j'ai utilisé un bon réseau quand je me
suis lancée dans l'entrepreneuriat
j'ai voulu faire cavalier seul c'est
peut-être la plus grosse erreur
professionnelle de ma carrière
à partir du moment où j'ai élargi mon
genre mon réseau et j'ai trouvé par
exemple un mentor j'ai fait un saut
quantique
à partir du moment où j'ai trouvé un
réseau ou ceux qui composaient le réseau
faisais dix fois avant fil d'affaires
j'ai fait un saut quantique à partir du
moment que j'ai trouvé un réseau où 50%
de la salle était plus bruyant que moi
je rentrais dans une salle il ya des
gens plus brillants
j'ai fait un saut quantique
tout ça pour vous dire que lapierre
numéro un c'est votre réseau c'est leur
raison et c'est justement cela c'est
justement cette pierre là que les femmes
ne cultive pas que les femmes
n'utilisent pas par manque de temps
première pierre le raison quelques
années plus tard je dirige un magazine
féminin sur la réussite au féminin du
coup et je me retrouve à devoir
convaincre les femmes d'être interviewé
dans le magazine est loin de ne pas du
tout en tant que rédactrice en chef
d'avoir une partie de mon job qui
consiste à convaincre les femmes d'être
interviewés et cette mise en lumière et
je me rappelle d'une femme en
particulier je sens et histoire à vous
raconter je me rappelle d'une qui m'a
marqué une femme qui avait redressé
plusieurs entités d'une crosse lois
françaises
kate est prise en otage et qu'il dit une
interview - pourquoi qu'est ce que j'ai
à vous raconter et dans le même temps si
j'interviens aussi quelques hommes donc
des aumônes able to believe et rennes
j'ai combien de pages de la voix en
avoir plus je me rappelle des femmes qui
en route vers des postes de direction
n'avait pas de visuel des 100
présentable affaires publié dans le
magazine et en parallèle leurs
homologues masculins
imz eh oui ou les pois en pierrot trois
quarts en coffret et moi ça devient co
aussi à mon histoire personnelle parce
que je suis une grande timide à
l'origine et j'ai passé toute ma
scolarité à ramasser des crayons
imaginaire tombée sur le sol dès que le
prof demandait si quelqu'un voulait
passer au tableau
en fait j'avais plus peur de la peur du
jugement alors j'étais bons élèves en
plus et s'aggravent jt nous les parents
et des super night ferrand prévôt nelly
est en fait la peur du jugement ne pas
paralyser
à tel point que je n'osais même pas
prendre un peu de lumière et cette peur
du jugement et cette peur d'être en
lumière m'a vraiment pas réalisé tout au
long de ma carrière et je me remets en
2014 quand challenge m'appelle et me dit
voilà on vous met dans le prochain
challenge la liste des 100 startups où
il faut investir en france moi pour moi
je voyais que les réflexes sont tenaces
deuxième
hier la visibilité on viendra pas nous
chercher
donc c'est à vous de vous mettre en
valeur c'est à vous de faire entre
guillemets votre plan de communication
et seul un coup double à caumont sorti
beaucoup de femmes vivent heureux vivons
cachés bien vrai qu au réseau ne pas à
personne les dollars vous les enlevez
donc la visibilité est derrière la
visibilité entoure à l'invisibilité plus
tôt puisque j'ai interviewé trois sans
fin qui n'osaient pas se mettre en
valeur
derrière ça à chaque fois que les
interviewés et je voyais qu'il y avait
des réussites brillante des résultats
incroyables des parcours remarquables et
derrière ça les femmes se cachait
toujours vert derrière non mais c'est
mon équipe
non mais c'est la conjoncture j'ai
beaucoup de chance donc derrière la
visibilité il ya une mode fier à creuser
et celle là elle est fondamentale si
vous voulez vraiment avancer c'est la
confiance en soi
donc si on prend les trois réseaux
visibilité confiance en soi les trois
nous avait les trois pierres qui envoyé
avec une certaine dextérité peuvent
biaiser le plafonnement ya une condition
il ya trois conditions qui ont accéléré
la mise en place de la mixité
quand j'ai organisé une forme d'un
mixité pendant six ans donc le plus
grand événement sur la liste et en
france j'ai très vite constaté
premièrement quand fait que ce sujet
était ou féminin qui avait que les
femmes qui s'intéressent à ce sujet de
la mixité
il a donc cité withers un peu comme le
tango quoi et je me disais et surtout
les hommes génération x donc la mine se
désintéresser complètement du sujet est
donc une condition qui accélère le fait
de promouvoir la mixité c'est justement
d'avoir ces les hommes à nos côtés des
hommes
xxx est ma génération c'est 60 80
1960-1980 donc avoir les hommes à ses
côtés accélère la viande de lanester
deuxième point ce que j'ai remarqué
aussi dans le forum on faisait des think
tanks beaucoup de think tanks et quand
on a des femmes
qu'est ce qui vous permet prêtre choisir
un job plutôt qu'un autre
outre l'intérêt du job la réponse numéro
2 c'était est-ce que ce job me permet de
concilier vie pro vie privée d'avoir
j'aime pas trop ça fait du bien d'avoir
une articulation et en in situ dix ans
une articulation et tendent dans le sens
coup présentéisme week-end sacrifier
journées à rallonge
s'il faut ça pour avoir le job j'en veux
pas et c'est là où la notion du temps et
là nous façon dont les entreprises vont
gérer cette possibilité au niveau du
temps est crucial et si une entreprise
aujourd'hui veut faire monter les femmes
si un secteur veut attirer les femmes et
qui est plus de mixité
il faut savoir prendre en compte cette
notion étant donc les hommes le temps et
troisième point en facilitant
accélérateur la génération y dans l'eau
c'est vous 80 à 2000 ça un moyen de
jouer suis rendu compte au forum la
mixité dans les think tanks encore que
finalement cette flexibilité demandé sur
le temps ce refus du présentéisme marque
hot wheels et le télétravail oui le
travail par mission oui finalement ces
revendications étaient les mêmes que
celles de la génération y a intéressant
donc c'est clair que si nous femmes x on
collabore avec vous génération y
xy mot compte triple loin on accélère
considérablement l'effet de promouvoir
la mixité dans l'entreprise dans la
société
et là ça devient intéressant parce que
quand on regarde ce qu'avaient prédit
note sociologues et psychologues
américains dans les années 2000 sur
l'économie et sur la valeur sociétale
oui sur le développement personnel à
fond sur la présence des femmes
on a eu les propos les chiffres fut pas
les rappeler mais j'en ai d'autres dans
la dernière étude du fortune 500 paru
2018 donc ses frais on a 5 % de femmes
guignol je suis de 25% par rapport à
l'année précédente
d'autres si on veut faire accélérer la
journal la mixité et si moi je veux le
voir de mon vivant je vous propose un
pacte faisons alliance bout d y moi les
x et avançons ensemble pour publier le
plafond d'heures merci
[Applaudissements]